holy [ __ ] that was a [ __ ] trip man so
Mandy is actually the name of my
childhood dog funny enough but this man
needs a movie starring Nicolas Cage you
would how to describe this one very long
psychedelic acid trip back to the
eighties story short ickle is caged and
his wife or girlfriend whichever they
live in the middle of nowhere in the
woods which is always a bad recipe in a
movie something Bad's gonna happen to
you if those are your living conditions
then a creepy evil cult gets ahold of
them and then kills her and then Nicolas
Cage is out for revenge
again very long LSD field trip short and
is this movie totally cashing in on the
80s nostalgia porn way that's hitting
the world yeah that wave is straight-up
real right now because everyone's like
today sucks I want to go back to when it
didn't suck funny enough people have
always sucked you're not gonna find a
decade or time where they didn't that
said I always enjoy some 80's nostalgia
but it can't be all there is to a movie
I just [ __ ] up weird is this movie is
not all there is to this movies movies
actually quite layered it's fun to think
about it's fun after the movies over to
think about all right what did that mean
was that a meaning for something else
and you look into it you go down the
rabbit hole and you're like oh yeah
apparently but really this is Nicolas
Cage in the pocket this is where he
shines because the movies absurd Nicolas
Cage is absurd it's just totally worked
his absurdity only amplifies the absurd
movie and symbiotically this absurd
movie only amplifies Nicolas Cage what
is it really work if this movie was made
for anyone else I'd be totally surprised
and is this movie a fuelled bloodbath
absolutely however keeping your
expectations and Jack had a lot of
people like you need to see Mandy you
need to see so I finally saw Mandy and I
was like alright so it's not exactly
that for most of the movie it's a trip
for most of the movie but the revenge
carnage you might be coming for it
doesn't really come into play until well
into the second half of the movie in
that there are some artsy-fartsy s
people out there I know who like the
artsy fartsy [ __ ] in here the slow burn
the crawl those moments where someone
looks over at someone else in the musics
playing and this tear comes out and I'm
like [ __ ] this is why I don't watch a
lot of Indies cuz I just roll my eyes at
that [ __ ] I just do I can't help it I'm
like a stop it just seems indulging his
[ __ ] like the directors like oh yeah
like all over my face I'm like but it
has it's carnage it has it sick ass
twisted villains in it too not just the
cult leader cuz he's a weirdo it's funny
like is that [ __ ] Thomas Wayne from
Batman Begins totally is whether these
evil biker demon things like threw the
thing in here where I was like pretty
sure this movie's not
really tell them a story about human
beings I mean Nicolas Cage human being
but these aren't people so I'm gonna go
ahead and say that they're demons or at
least as demon is someone who doesn't
really have a budget wants to tell the
story that's essentially Mad Max [ __ ]
the album cover of an 80s death metal
band it's always fun to see them bite it
at the hands of crazy Nicolas Cage again
in the second half of the second half of
the movement I just want people coming
back in my comments section saying I
said it was like Mad Max fury road it
was super octane the entire time know
it's like first Mad Max original Mad Max
was a unique experience first half of
this movie I was like what the [ __ ] is
going then by the second half I fell
into it I was like okay I get it you
know I was able slip into it just have a
good time guys in the end I enjoyed this
movie I want to say what a lot of people
did not tell me this movie's not for
everybody
sometimes the pace doesn't always pick
up sometimes seems just seems like their
lives forever
I really love the nuance I love the tone
I love the fact that as the movie
progresses and Nic Cage goes down the
precipice of madness all the neon colors
start becoming more pronounced by the
end of the movie you're in and neon bulb
I committed a huge transgression in this
movie that I didn't know was gonna be a
transgression and that was i watch this
movie sober I'm not talking about
alcohol I'm talking about weed you gotta
be [ __ ] high I have a rule don't do
that [ __ ] when I'm watching a movie
because they'll just impede my judgement
unless I reviewed a movie in which you
hated the review and you don't agree
with it in which case yeah sure go ahead
and bleep out some movies straight up
when I was watching I was like you are
meant to watch this stone not advocating
drug use if you don't do that [ __ ]
that's cool good on you not condoning or
condemning I'm just saying it's real
this is a reality of the situation here
so if you smoke weed take edibles
whatever I found the movie for you enjoy
this is where my rating system you have
to remember it's medicinal I'm telling
you just the facts of the matter I'll
say Mandy was a good time no alcohol
required and even better if you're a
little [ __ ] high yeah now it's a
party again just saying
alright so Mandy have you seen it what
did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]